non moi ce qui m'a énormément trouver
dans cette affaire c'est que j'ai occupé
des fonctions je suis identifié dans mon
parti comme étant une protectrice des
femmes
comment est ce possible que ce ne soit
pas jamais remonter jusqu'à mes oreilles
est ce que j'en ai discuté avec d'autres
collègues la direction provisoire du
parti d'union nationale je veux savoir
aujourd'hui comment
non je veux comprendre d'abord je veux
comprendre enquête interne potter oui
oui voila j'ai effectivement on peut
appeler ça une inclut une enquête
interne faudra trouver un mot qui soit
plus que l'omerta là je veux pas de
laboeuf carottes de cette affaire il ya
une omerta sur ce sujet je vais que je
veux comprendre comment est ce possible
que des comportements de ce type pas qui
a tiré marche impec des tirs et marshall
bec en a partout et il ya
malheureusement il y en aura encore
d'autres à la fin à l'issue de tout ça
c'est comment est ce possible qu'un
individu soumettent des femmes autour de
lui que elle ne serait elle conserve sa
pour elle même ou que ce qu'elle en
parle ne puisse pas réglée et on a tous
un problème en fait qui est une espèce
de corporatisme traquons pourparlers
très concrètement il ya des gens qui ont
couvert selon vous jésus marshall bugs
mais c'est ce que je veux savoir
je ne sais je ne dirais pas couverts je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui ont
probablement ont pas mesuré n'ont pas su
comment faire
cousineau a - avaient été avertis en
2015 par une militante sur le sur le
sujet il n'a rien fait a priori c'est ce
que dit la libération mais justement
quand je dis il faut qu'il y ait une
travail d' enquête interne pour
comprendre c'est pas simplement les
responsabilités ce une affaire qui date
de 2011 2013 donc mais c'est pas ça mon
sujet mon sujet c'est comment on peut
faire pour que ça ne se reproduise pas
chez nous et mais chez les autres